House Republicans have officially kicked
ilhan Omar off the Foreign Affairs
committee and fellow Squad member AOC is
not happy about it
as also as a fellow New Yorker I think
one of the things that we should talk
about here is also one of the disgusting
legacies after 9 11 has been the
targeting and racism against Muslim
Americans throughout the United States
of America and this is an extension of
that Legacy consistency there is nothing
consistent with the Republican party's
continued attack except for the racism
and incitement of violence against women
of color in this body I had a member of
the Republican caucus threaten my life
and you all and the Republican caucus
rewarded him with one of the most
prestigious committee assignments in
this Congress don't tell me this is
about consistency don't tell me that
this is about an ABS a condemnation of
anti-semitic remarks when you have a
member of the Republican caucus who has
talked about Jewish space lasers and an
entire amount of tropes and also
elevated her to some of the highest
committee assignments in this body this
is about targeting women of color in the
in the United States of America don't
tell me because I didn't get a single of
time has expiring my life was threatened
thank you
hey
AOC went on a rant there about herself
as she always does but let's get back to
the first part since we're here to talk
about ilhan Omar aoc's argument is that
ilhan Omar is the victim of islamophobia
which AOC cites as one of the worst
legacies of 9 11.
one of the worst Legacies
like you you think about 9 11 and you're
you're trying to identify the worst
thing about 9 11 and the answer you come
up with is
islamophobia AOC actually just performed
a Norm Macdonald bit on the floor of the
House of Representatives
I can't say my friend's name but he said
his biggest fear
is
that Isis or some terrorist group like
that would get a hold of a dirty bomb
and exploded over a major city within
the United States
and kill
tens of millions of people
because then
the blowback against
innocent Muslims would be absolutely
terrible
yeah that's that's right that's true
okay let's do some jokes
that's it that would be the worst part
of it would be the blowback
the worst thing imaginable islamophobia
but islamophobia whatever that means is
not white ilahan Umar was removed from
the Foreign Affairs committee she was
removed because of the things that she
has said and done to prove that we can't
trust her with matters of foreign policy
and National Security the House
Republicans were threatening to do it
now they've done it ilhan Omar is off
the Foreign Affairs committee here's
Kevin McCarthy explaining the reasoning
now when it comes to congresswoman Omar
based upon what she had said the
anti-semitic comments
It's All About the Benjamins
the the military in America is equal to
Hamas and the Taliban on 9 11 something
happened that day even the former
Democratic chair of the committee
believed her comments were wrong when a
resolution was brought up to deal with
this last time she never apologized they
changed the resolution to say
anti-Semitism is wrong
we're not removing her from other
committees we just do not believe when
it comes to Foreign Affairs especially
the responsibility of that position
around the world with the comments that
you make
she shouldn't serve there but this is
what the clear this if it was Tit for
Tat we would have picked people took
them off all committees and said nothing
about we don't believe in that all right
that's the argument now the first reason
that Kevin McCarthy cites for booting
ilhan Omar off the Foreign Affairs
committee is her anti-semitism
and anti-Semitism very very bad I I
don't know if ilhan Omar hates the Jews
or not she very well might hate the Jews
but that would not be the primary reason
to kick somebody off the Foreign Affairs
committee and the reason for that is if
not liking the Jews is the threshold now
for kicking people off congressional
committees
they're probably some more people who
would have to be kicked off of
committees certainly in the Democratic
party certainly among the squad I think
that would probably take people out if
if not liking Israel
uh we're we're the bar there would be a
lot more people who would have to be
removed from their congressional
committees especially we're talking
about Israel very controversial facet of
foreign policy for the last century but
let's zoom out a little bit let's take
the Jews out of it for a second if
racial
or religious resentment were the new
threshold for kicking people off
congressional committees
you you'd have to lose probably half the
Democrat Party
how many Democrat members of Congress
have openly expressed antipathy for
white people said that whiteness is a
bad thing we need fewer white people in
in public life we we need less about
white people taught in schools
half the part more than half the party
what about antipathy toward Christians
half the party more than half the party
expressing a desire to to minimize the
role of Christianity in American public
life America country founded on
Christianity that bar sorry to say is
probably too low for removing someone
from a congressional committee
racial or religious resentment you'd
probably lose most of the people on your
committees at least roughly half of them
no the reason the primary reason
that ilhan Omar should not serve on the
Foreign Affairs committee is not because
of what she said about one racial group
or about one religious group it's
because of what she said about America
and the enemies who have explicitly
attacked America
because they recognize that that people
did something
and that all of us were starting to lose
access to our civil liberties the thing
that was interesting in the class was
every time the the the professor said
Al-Qaeda he sort of like his shoulders
went up and you know yeah
Al-Qaeda you know he's an expert
but it is it is that you don't say
America with an intensity you don't say
England with the intensity you know you
don't you don't say
um the army with an intensity
but you say these these names because
you you want that that word to carry
weight
Al Qaeda
Osama Bin Laden and it's so crazy right
I mean we say Al-Qaeda like it's big and
scary but we don't say the same thing
about America or the army so she's
saying that that if we view Al-Qaeda
with any more antipathy or fear then we
would view the United States and the
American Military then that's just sort
of silly it's we should be giggling
about that that's so crazy that's why
she should be removed from the
Committees
because she giggles at and seems to side
with America's enemies who have attacked
America
if we broaden this out too much and we
say well if you make a comment about
this racial group or this religious
group or this other Nation then that
disbars you from from serving on a
congressional committee then that gives
an opening to the Democrats it gives an
opening to AOC to say well Marjorie
Taylor green allegedly said something
about Jewish space lasers by the way
I've never heard this comment I've never
seen this comment I see it frequently
cited by the left but I've never heard
Marjorie Taylor green say anything that
makes me think she hates the Jews but
the the libs will use that they'll say
well look at this person look he's
expressed a kind of antipathy toward
this racial group or that religious
group or this that or the other thing
it's it's too low it's very clear it
doesn't need to be this this highly
emotional decision with AOC screaming
her head off and gesticulating like a
mad woman to to remove ilhan Omar
ilhan Omar
has made light of the worst terror
attack in American history ilhan Omar
has taken the side of America's enemies
openly
the enemy is specifically involved in
that terror attack and she obviously has
no business on the Foreign Affairs
committee Kevin McCarthy cites those
comments as well he cites them a little
later down the line which I think is
what gives an opening to the Democrats
to criticize this decision this is an
obvious decision obviously this woman
should have absolutely nothing to do
with American National Security or
American foreign policy she was elected
by her constituents so I guess she
should continue to serve in Congress she
can even serve on some of the other
committees but get that lady away from
foreign policy and National Security
especially now as as we're in probably
the most fraught dangerous period for
National Security and foreign policy
certainly in 20 years maybe in a lot
longer than that maybe since the Cold
War as you see aggression from Russia
that threatens to destabilize Europe as
you're seeing aggression from China
which is now sending spy balloons over
the continental United States time to
reduce the threats to American National
Security including in the U.S Congress
the show continues now
not for you Hoy polloi over on YouTube
but for the creme de La Creme the Inner
Circle at dailywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles at checkout you get two months
free on all annual plans we will see you
there
[Music]
foreign